[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers einen
guten Samstagabend ihnen allen wenn man
zu lange in den Abgrund schaut dann
schaut der Abgrund irgendwann zu
mit diesem Gedanken des Philosophen
Friedrich Nietsche hat der fdpchef heute
Mut machen wollen den deutschen
Christian Lindner sagt er habe den
Eindruck hier greife die Lust am
Untergang um sich irgendwie passt das
ganze aber auch auf die Lage seiner
eigenen Partei die FDP hält heute ihr
traditionelles Dreikönigstreffen ab und
sie kämpft in den Umfragen praktisch
überall wo es dieses Jahr drauf ankommt
mit der 5% Hürde Luisa Huben
berichtet öen war einer der ersten der
dafür stimmte dafür dass die FDP die
Ampel verlässt ein wegruf sollte die
basisabstimmung sein sie scheiterte
knapp beim Dreikönigstreffen in
Stuttgart hoffen öen und seine
Mitstreiter dass die Parteispitze
trotzdem reagiert sofern ist das knappe
Ergebnis für uns ein Zeichen dass doch
die überwiegende Zahl der Mitglieder
hier ganz muliges Gefühl hat und sagen
wir wollen jetzt klare Entscheidung
haben wir wollen auch dass ihr euch klar
positioniert auf Bundesebene damit wir
wissen wo es in Zukunft hingeht doch
konkret spricht parteichf Lindner im
Stuttgarter Opernhaus den basisentscheid
nicht an stattdessen verteidigt er die
bisherige
ampelpolitik Bundesregierung
handelt sie ist nicht
fehlerfrei wer wäre das aber wir
entscheiden mehr richtig als falsch denn
sonst würde die FDP dieser Regierung
nicht angehören er wirbt für Optimismus
wohl auch mit Blick auf das Wahljahr es
stehen drei Landtagswahlen und die
Europawahl an gewinnen soll letztere sie
Spitzenkandidatin Marie Agnes Strack
Zimmermann euphorisch begrüßt im Saal
ein europafak sei sie sagt Stck
Zimmermann und sorgt sich um die Zukunft
der EU die
Nationalisten sind toxisch und
gefährlich meine Damen und Herren das
ist nicht profan denn letztendlich
werden Politikerin und Politiker und
dazu gehört die AFD hört auch Frau
Wagenknecht dazu in die EU reinwollen um
sie von innen kaputt zu machen
kämpferisch zeigt sie sich weckt
Hoffnung dass die FDP in Wählerumfragen
wieder zulegen könnte bundesweit liegt
sie derzeit um 5% in den ostdeutschen
Ländern in denen 2024 gewählt wird g
drunter doch die Debatten um Haushalt
und Schuldenbremse laufen schon wieder
wegen des verheerenden Hochwassers und
den wütenden Landwirten auch hier in
Stuttgart fordern Sie heute weiter die
geplanten Kürzung zurückzunehmen Lindner
erteilt dem eine Absage für die FDP
dürfte es in der Ampel 2024 nicht
leichter werden fürchtet Wolfgang öen
ich hte mir schon gewünscht dass wir
heute ein bisschen klarer nach vorne
kommen dass auch bisschen klarer sagt wo
die Abgrenzung zu den Koalitionspartnern
stattfinden soll das kam heute nicht und
das ist das war ein bisschen
enttäuschend und doch Klatsch sie sich
am Ende Mut zu für ein herausforderndes
Jahr denn sollte die FDP in den
kommenden Wahlen abgestraft werden
dürften die Rufe nach einem
ampelausstieg wieder lauter
werden neues Jahr und dennoch ein déjavu
eine Wahl auf die die ganze Welt guckt
könnte zu einem Duell werden dass die
ganze Welt schon mal in Atem gehalten
hat beiden gegen Trump im November
entscheiden die Wählerinnen und Wähler
in den USA der amtierende Präsident geht
jetzt zur Attacke über er sagt zur
Abstimmung stünden diesmal nicht nur er
und ein Kontrahent sondern nichts
anderes als Demokratie und Freiheit der
Zeitpunkt ist kein Zufall der 6 Januar
da war doch was Elma
Tissen ein begeistertes Publikum gehört
zu einer guten Inszenierung natürlich
auch die klare Botschaft in diesem Fall
die Warnung vor einem
Schreckgespenst Donald Trumps Wahlkampf
ist besessen von der Vergangenheit nicht
der Zukunft er will unsere Demokratie
Opfern und sich selbst ermächtigen wir
wissen wer Donal Trump wir müssen die
Frage beantworten wer wir sind das steht
auf dem Spiel wer sind
wir stehen die Amerikaner noch für
Demokratie diese Frage stellte beiden
passend in Valley Forge dem Ort des
winterlagers von George Washington
1777 aus verzweifelter Lage führte er
damals seine Armee am Ende siegreich
gegen die Truppen des englischen Königs
eines Tyrannen danach hätte er sich
selbst zum König machen können aber
Washington gab die Macht zurück zu sehen
im Gemälde im Kapitol das sie am 6
Januar 2021 erstürmten angespornt von
Donald Trump und der so behauptet beiden
wollen nun vollenden was ihm damals
nicht gelang Amerika in eine Diktatur
verwandeln schon jetzt spreche er die
Sprache der
Tyrannen er nennt alle die gegen ihn
sind ungezieer er sagt Amerikas Blut
werde von Zuwanderer vergiftet das ist
exakt die gleiche Sprache wie eins den
Nazi
Deutschland Trumps Anhänger die vor
seinem Auftritt in Iowa in der Kälte
ausharren mögen seine Schimpftiraden und
Sie glauben dass in Wahrheit vor allem
das FBI hinter der Gewalt vom 6 Januar
steckte 25% aller Amerikaner sind davon
überzeugt 44% der
trumpwähler vieles was da am 6 Januar
passiert ist das lag nicht an den
trumphäng das waren die die man
eingeschleust hat die Opposition hat sie
da
reingeschickt auch Trump behauptet das
und spottet über beidens Botschaft von
Val for er sagt ich sei eine Bedrohung
für die
Demokratie
Demokratie er konnte das Wort nicht
einmal
lesen ich werde am ersten Tag ein
Diktator sein um dasben zuauben zu
schließen danach werde ich kein Diktator
sein Trump behauptet die wahre Bedrohung
für die Demokratie sei beiden es wird
ein Wahlkampf in dem beide Seiten Ängste
schüren die Wähler müssen nun
entscheiden wer dabei lügt und wer dabei
die Wahrheit
spricht seit mehr als 22 langen Monaten
Wert die Ukraine eine russische Invasion
ab dieses Jahr zu überleben bedeutet den
gesamten Krieg zu überleben sagt der
ukrainische Präsident und kündigt heute
an die Rüstungsproduktion des Landes
massiv
hochzufahren aber Panzer und Raketen
sind nicht alles wer aktuell an der
Front kämpft wartet sehnsüchtig auf
Ablösung heute ist der
682 Tag des Krieges und genau da haakt
es gewaltig es ist das Thema dass in der
Ukraine die Gespräche bestimmt die
Regierung braucht dringend weitere
Soldaten eine neue mobilisierungswelle
droht und gleichzeitig schwindet das
Vertrauen in die Art und Weise wie da
ausgewählt wird zeigt meine Kollegin
Alisa
jung sie üben hier den Kampf an der
Front junge Menschen die vorbereitet
sein wollen für den Fall dass sie bald
kämpfen
müssen es wird nicht bequem sein kämpfen
ist immer unbequem erklärt der Ausbilder
die Stadt Kiev bietet das Training
kostenlos an die Kurse sind voll denn
die Regierung hat deutlich gemacht sie
braucht mehr Männer für den Kampf ich
habe viele Freunde die aktuell dienen
und ich weiß dass auch meine Zeit kommen
wird auch für jene die gesundheitlich
nicht die fittesten und quasi halbblind
sind wie ich auch wir werden eines Tages
an die Front müssen um andere
abzulösenxchenko versucht zu scherzen
weiß aber das Thema ist
ernst am Anfang ist man sehr verloren
und deshalb ist es wichtig sich diese
Fähigkeiten anzueignen wenn das
gefährlichste mm Plastikkugel ist und
keine aus
Blei in jeder Stadt wirbt das Militär
für sich zerstör den Feind kämpf in der
dritten
angriffbrigade doch das wollen einige
nicht verstecken sich zu Hause aus Sorge
vom Militär aufgegriffen und eingezogen
zu werden wie Alex in Odessa der nur mit
uns spricht weil wir sein Gesicht nicht
zeigen und echten Namen nicht
verraten
ich durchlaufe einen standardisierten
Prozess da werden keine Fragen gestellt
was ich kann und meine Fähigkeiten
werden
ignoriert und ich kann nicht zeigen wie
ich nützlich sein
kann mehr Transparenz und mehr Vertrauen
daran will die Regierung nun arbeiten um
Männer zu überzeugen hat Agenturen
engagiert die Online die Möglichkeit
geben
eigenealifikation einzutragen und dann
passende Stellen beim Militär
finden wir geben Zivilisten die
Möglichkeit die militärische Einheit und
Position zu wählen damit Sie entscheiden
können wo und als was sie
dienen es geht zuallererst um Sicherheit
und Klarheit für deine Zukunft sofern
das eben
geht ein Problem bleibt manche Jobs wie
in der IT wollen viele an die vorderste
Front weniger unklar wie wie sie das
lösen wollen Alex sagt er war nicht
vorbereitet in einem Land im Krieg zu
leben das nicht genug Hilfe aus dem
Westen bekommt um zu
gewinnen unsere Regierung sagt die
Mobilisierung muss laufen weil wir Leute
brauchen Männer werden getötet und
verletzt und wir müssen sie ersetzen er
fühle sich wie ein Werkzeug das die
Regierung braucht und nimmt um etwas zu
bauen doch die Werkzeuge seien
endlich so jetzt weitere Nachrichten
hier von diesem Samstag Abend in der
Übersicht und die hast du Hanna die
winterklausur der CSU Landesgruppe in
klosteron ist mit scharfer Kritik an der
Ampelkoalition gestartet es habe noch
nie eine Regierung mit so wenig
Vertrauen bei der Bevölkerung gegeben
sagte CSU Chef Söder zum Auftakt und
erneuerte seine Forderung nach zeitnahen
Neuwahlen bei dem dreitägigen Treffen
soll es unter anderem um die kommenden
Landtagswahlen in Ostdeutschland und das
Thema Migration
gehen usßenminister linken hat sich vor
seiner mehrtägigen Reise in den Nahen
Osten mit dem türkischen Präsidenten
Erdogan getroffen dieser ist ein
scharfer Kritiker Israels und gibt sich
als Sympathisant der Terrororganisation
Hamas Lord blinken wolle die Türkei
dennoch dazu beitragen einen
Flächenbrand in der Region zu verhindern
unterdessen feuerte die hisbolla Miliz
im Libanon nach eigenen Angaben 62
Raketen auf den Norden Israels Ziel war
ein
Militärstützpunkt der Angriff sei eine
erste Reaktion auf die Tötung eines
hamasanführers am Dienstag in
Beirut Bundespräsident Steinmeier und
seine Frau Elke büdenbänder haben heute
im Schloss belvü Sternsinger aus dem
Bistum Limburg empfangen die Jungen und
Mädchen stehen stellvertreten für alle
Sternsinger die sich bundesweit an der
Aktion beteiligen in diesem Jahr werden
Spenden für den Erhalt des Amazonas
regenwals
gesammelt der Japaner Ryu Kobayashi hat
die 72 vierschancenournee gewonnen und
einen Sieg von Andreas Wellinger
verhindert der in der Gesamtwertung auf
Platz 2 landete beim Abschluss springen
im Bischofshofen lag Wellinger deutlich
hinter dem Japaner der die Tournee nun
zum dritten Mal gewonnen hat bereits
2019 und 2023 holte sich Kobayashi den
Goldadler mehr dazu gleich nach uns im
Aktuellen
Sportstudio zu den lottezahlen an diesem
Samstag
3 5 14 18 34 47 Superzahl 7 alle Angaben
wie immer ohne Gewehr in den nächsten
Tagen wird es teils frostig die
Wetteraussichten im Süden lässt der
Schneefall morgen nur langsam nach an
der Donau und am Rhein kann auch Regen
dabei sein kräftige Schneeschauer gibt
es auch von Vorpommern bis ins nördliche
Brandenburg sonst bleibt es trocken bei
eisigem Wind werden -4 bis + 4° erreicht
mit frostigen Temperaturen zwischen -7
und + 3° und viel Sonne geht es in den
nächsten Tagen
weiter jeder einzelne Flug ist ein
Wunder finde ich zumindest wenn diese
Kisten mit hunderten Menschen an Bord
tatsächlich abheben und dann sicher
wieder landen ein echtes Flugzeug Wunder
haben wir ja bereits Anfang dieser Woche
erlebt in Japan als alle
379 Menschen an Bord aus einem lichalow
brennenden Airbus entkommen konnten
heute ein weiterer Albtraum für
Flugpassagiere der ebenfalls gerade noch
mal gut ausging das ist Alaska Airlines
Flug
1282 die Maschine verliert in 4900 m
Höhe einen Teil der Kabinenwand samt
Fenster ohrenbetäubender Lärm heftiger
Luftstrom durch das Loch sehen die
Passagiere in die schwarze Nacht doch
die Maschine kann umkehren nach Portland
Oregon und sicher landen es ist eine
Boeing 737 MAX ein Typ der mehrfach
katastrophale Probleme hatte mehr als
170 Maschinen des Typs müssen in den USA
jetzt erstmal am Boden bleiben bis sie
genau überprüft wurden der Chef der
Airline übrigens wandte sich an seine
Passagiere die noch mal mit dem
Schrecken davon gekommen sind und sagte
es tut mir so leid was sie erlebt
haben ja gerade noch mal gut ja das kann
man wohl sagen in diesem Sinne einen
ruhigen und schönen Abend noch und bis
morgen tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss